well look you've uh you've had a hell of
a
Redemption story that you're still doing
man yeah I ain't stopping I got some the
ketamine Clinic you heard the academy
I've heard about how it can be like
beneficial
I don't know the details though so maybe
you can I got these um these clinics
coming out maybe you can make have you
um try it out well what what is it
because we heard a cat like I know
ketamine like the party drug right not
the party drop right because they're
starting people can get stuck in a k
hole no done this way
I'm sure can help with
PTSD depression and addiction yeah I've
heard about that I think in today's
society I probably need it because
everybody's suffering from one to the
other
after we all kind of after the pandemic
just
basically put us in jail basically the
last two years right
anybody not really meant to do a bit you
ain't lying you feel me yeah so a lot of
people lost their minds so you have
you're you you have like a ketamine
Clinic that where people can kind of
safely administer it for therapeutic
purposes
no it's about to I'm about to partner up
with Academy is that something that
you've actually done and it was helpful
I don't get high that's great man I
don't think about getting high as fast
as I think about that word cocaine come
in my mouth
they leave
what is like uh would you say you know
workers work every day in my
relationship with God yeah I spoke my
marijuana that's about it wheat is fine
I think I think I think we all know like
we I think weed and psychedelics should
just you know I I don't know if we can
consider those drugs because they're so
beneficial
well I think for some people marijuana
opens the Gateway that's what goes it's
true it is true so have you not really
strong and disciplined right
knowledgeable about marijuana
you know what I'm saying you need to
know everything about it before you
indulging heavy
yeah I mean
I know people who started smoking weed
and then I mean I I mean yeah I think
it's definitely a game it's a certain
truth to it I don't know people some
people don't smoke weed would never [ __ ]
with cocaine or anything else you hardly
ever find somebody who's never smoked
weed but they're huge cokeheads
like show me that guy yeah I've never
smoked in my life but I love [ __ ]
Coke yeah yeah
that shit's crazy
so you don't even think about cocaine
anymore
that's good man
I don't know
do you do meetings nah I just stay close
to God
you know what I'm saying my little
ketamine sessions yeah
prey on it
I think I understand the um
risk and reward hmm
you feel me yeah it comes down to that
yeah the cat you did they do Academy and
they also do you would also do a MDMA
like a therapy
yeah for PTSD
let's get that party started right now
we'll get that prescription no no it's a
real thing though yeah yeah MDMA there's
like MDMA trials that help veterans get
through PTSD same thing with the
psilocybin the mushroom [ __ ] a lot of
that [ __ ] if administrated you know uh
properly that [ __ ] is beneficial but I
think that's what any drug honestly
except maybe not crack I don't know nah
nah
yeah it's yeah uh or cocaine I don't
think nothing could be beneficial about
cocaine